y buenos días efectivamente la república
dominicana es de los pocos países en el
mundo que todavía mantiene una
penalización absoluta del aborto lo que
implica que en el país las mujeres en
situaciones especiales tienen que acudir
a la práctica del aborto de condiciones
de riesgo y de esa manera afectando su
salud en el país el 13 por ciento de la
muerte materna se deben precisamente al
aborto en condiciones de gesto pero
tenemos otros factores también
vinculante a esta situación es el país
que tiene la mayor proporción en la
región de embarazos en adolescentes y
alrededor de una cuarta
de la población adolescente ha estado
embarazada
igualmente república dominicana posee
uno de los índices más altos de
matrimonio infantil el 12 por ciento de
nuestras niñas se unen o se casan antes
de los 15 años igualmente hay una gran
necesidad insatisfecha de métodos
anticonceptivos por ejemplo en los
trabajadores gente alrededor del 30% no
tiene acceso a métodos anticonceptivos
de igual manera y república dominicana
también de los pocos países de la región
que no tiene educación sexual en las
escuelas
durante todos estos años desde que se
introduce la modificación al código
penal hemos estado en la calle luchando
para que se incluyan esas tres causales
que son aspectos extraordinarios son
situaciones de fuerza mayor que obligan
a una mujer
a poner en riesgo su vida cuando corre
el peligro de su vida tenemos ejemplos
dolorosos en el país del caso de
esperancita una adolescente que
necesitaba interrumpir el embarazo
porque tenía la plástica y ella murió y
así entendimos
sería el presidente del país luis
savidan él afirmó en campaña defender
las tres causales que ustedes piden
ahora quiere someterla a referendo
porque rechazan ustedes esto
que efectivamente el presidente de la
república esa fue una de sus promesas de
campaña y de su propuesta de gobierno
rechazamos la propuesta de un referéndum
primero porque la propia constitución
dominicana establece que los derechos
fundamentales no pueden ser sometidos a
escrutinio de mayorías y el derecho a la
vida en derecho a la integridad ya la
dignidad son derechos fundamentales
igualmente en república dominicana el
proceso hasta poder llegar a ser un
referido es un proceso demasiado largo
estimamos que quizá 10 12 años porque
primero habría que aquí no tenemos una
líder
había que aprobar la ley en ese sentido
y después otra ley para el aborto y
luego que hacer
todo el proceso de organizarlo por unas
elecciones
sergia galván defensora de los derechos
de las mujeres gracias por acompañarnos
en france mente